zooming out uh in general in education
there's something called critical race
Theory
um can you comment on what are your
thoughts about uh
this kind of perspective on race and
race in America uh to the degree that
it's becoming a part of the education
program okay so the first thing I want
to say what is it well the first thing I
want to say about critical race theory
is that critical race theory has
become a term so I'm going to put
quotation marks around the term critical
race Theory
we can we I'm in a minute I'll talk
about critical race Theory without
quotation marks but to begin with I want
to talk about critical race Theory
because the reason why people are
talking about critical race Theory so
much now is because politicians
mainly Republican
right-wing politicians
have
created a boogeyman
critical race Theory with quotation
marks around it they have created a
boogeyman
and they have tried to make it seem as
though this Boogeyman
believes all sorts of ideas that
Americans should loathe and that
Americans should fear
and they've created this Boogeyman and
they've created it and they've done a
very good job of creating the Boogeyman
and they have mobilized uh sufficient uh
um you know public support such that you
know there are a number of states that
have passed laws
uh prohibiting
the teaching of so-called critical race
Theory now the first thing I want to say
about this is that
um this campaign this these laws these
various policies telling teachers don't
teach this and don't teach that and you
can't you can't use this book you can't
use that book this is a frightening
encroachment
on freedom
freedom of speech freedom to learn
freedom to listen freedom to read
that's terrible and it's one of the most
frightening things that has happened in
American Life in recent memory so that's
the first thing I want to say about
so-called critical race Theory now now
I'll say something I'm going to take the
quotation marks off of the term critical
race Theory
critical race theory is as a sort of a
you could have a nice conversation about
actually what it is
um one way of viewing it is to say that
well critical race theory is a community
of ideas
that comes from a community of people
the community of people would be people
in legal Academia
in the
um
you know the period 198 starting and
probably the middle of the 1980s
it would be associated with people like
Derek Bell it would be associated with
people like Kimberly Crenshaw people
like Charles Lawrence people like
Richard Delgado people like Mary matsuda
and these are folks who
held
uh embraced a couple of you know they
they articulated a couple of
propositions one of their propositions
was that
um
liberal
race policy
was insufficient
they would say that
um the racial policies of
a person like my old boss Thurgood
Marshall the lib you know the Liberal
Liberal racial policies were
insufficient to Grapple fully with the
pervasiveness and the depth and
intensity of American racism their their
basic claim and I think by the way it
was a good claim their basic claim was
that American racism is more Central
more deeply embedded in American Life
than uh most people perceived including
liberals and I think there was a lot of
strength to that proposition
um
but then they also took on some other
propositions with which I was in very
strong disagreement
so I think it's perfectly fine to say
that racism is a force in American Life
that is deeper more pervasive more
stubborn more resilient than I think
people often you know
often understand often perceive
but then some of the folks you know the
in critical race Theory
um push further
uh one of the propositions that some of
the people in critical race Theory took
was the proposition that um
uh America was doomed
to always be a country
that would be governed
according to the dictates of white
supremacy
uh Derek Bell who was a colleague of
mine and a friend of mine took that
position he talked about the permanence
of racism in American life and he took
the position that the various changes
that had been wrought in American Life
were really you know mainly cosmetic
uh they didn't amount to a whole lot I
mean Derrick Bell took the position you
know the second reconstruction the Civil
Rights Movement
well yeah it made changes but at the end
of the day black people were still you
know after the second reconstruction
were still in a position of
almost you know you know I don't know
some of them would even say Neo slavery
well I think that's ridiculous
uh the second reconstruction changed a
lot and as for Neo slavery neo-slavery
what are you talking about uh a black
American was President of the United
States between the years 2008 and 2016.
I mean what what are we talking about
here
uh there's been a tremendous change
and I think people ought to understand
that now
am I saying that everything is peachy
keen and all right no
uh the United States is still
uh to a very large extent still a
pigmentocracy but that doesn't mean that
a lot hasn't changed a lot has
so I disagree with certain tenets of
critical race Theory and have been very
outspoken in my disagreement there's
another one by the way I need to mention
because we've talked so much in our
discussion about freedom of speech
freedom to teach freedom of listening
another big problem that I've had with
some of the people who
talk of themselves as critical race
Theory people
has to do with their attitude towards
freedom freedom of speech
some critical race Theory people
think that
the American legal system is wrong
in the latitude
that it gives to what they call hate
speech or the latitude that it gives to
what they would view as racist beliefs
uh some of some of the people who
associate themselves with critical race
Theory think that racist beliefs
ought to be expunged
with the aid of state power if need be
well I'm against that
and
um you know I think we were at a moment
a an ironic moment
in which
actually it's the right wing that has
embraced some of the ideas that were
championed by some of this some of the
people who call themselves critical race
theorists you know they say oh we ought
to expunge
hate speech
well the right wing is saying this
critical race Theory that's hate speech
so let's expunge it
and
um so I you know again I've been very
outspoken in my criticism
of uh some of the illiberal
dimensions
of critical race Theory so I've you know
I've been a Critic of
certain features of critical race Theory
I have uh applauded certain features of
critical race Theory
um you know critical race Theory you
know there's some aspects of it that I
think have been useful there's some
aspects of it that I think have been you
know profoundly wrong-headed
um so that's where I am and I certainly
in you know above all
I certainly am against any efforts
to remove it
from you know the intellectual Universe
it is a part of our intellectual
Universe people ought to know about it
and people ought to debate it and people
ought to be free to make up their minds
to conclude what they will about the
stress and weaknesses of critical race
Theory